the go fast and the gimbal videos that
you mentioned earlier as well like
what's interesting there
to you
so the gimbal i'll talk about that one
first i was airborne for that one um the
person that recorded it as a good friend
of mine
but i mean both their crew i knew both
of them but the the wizard himself uh
very close friends went through a lot of
her training together
we went to the same fleet squadron uh he
ended up transitioning to be a pilot and
then came to where i was instructing so
i got to struck him a bit on his
transition
um
and you know the way that was was was we
went out on a
air-to-air training mission so
simulating an air fight against our own
guys they're acting like the bad guys
and kind of go head-to-head against each
other
and when we fly on those missions we all
fly out together more or less
we set up and then we kind of attrite
from the fight as we either you know run
out of gas or something happens and so
people usually go back onesies or
twosies
and so the aircrew that recorded the
gimbal they were going back to the boat
and we were on what's called a workup
training event and so this is like a
month on the boat
where we're essentially conducting
wartime operations more or less
to stress ourselves out and to kind of
do the last training block before we go
on deployment essentially so it's pretty
high stress
they actually do send aircraft from
like land bases to kind of try to
penetrate and we're expected to go
intercept them and so we're kind of
practicing like we play
and so
he saw these objects on the radar
um
the gimbal
and a fleet of other aircraft or
vehicles
and they initially thought it was uh
part of the training exercise that they
were sending something in to to try to
penetrate the airspace
um and so they you know they flew over
to it and as they got close enough to
get on the flear
um you know i think everyone has heard
their reaction um and they realized that
it wasn't something they were expecting
to see
can you actually describe what's in the
video what's the reaction in case they
haven't seen it yeah a lot of swearing
uh but so what you see on the flear
footage is a
black or white depending on when you
look at it object that's somewhat shaped
like a gimbal it appears almost as if
someone put two plates together
and then there seems to be almost like a
small funnel of ir energy that's at the
top of the bottom of those plates in a
sense so almost as if you know there's a
stick going in between two plates but
not that pronounced right so there's an
energy field that kind of went to a
funnel on the top and the bottom at
least that's how it was being portrayed
on the fleer
there's a lot of conversation about that
being glare things that nature but it
was actually a very tight ir image it
just was non-descript shape
which was interesting typically we would
see the skin of the aircraft we can see
the flames coming out of the exhaust
especially at those ranges
but and there was no flames or there's
no exhaust here there was no exhaust
there was no you know there was no out
outgassing of repellent in any manner
right it was just an object that had
nothing emitting from it that was
stationary in the sky we're not
stationary but it was it was um moving
along a path right it wasn't falling out
of the sky
and it continued along if we were to
consider it from a god's eye view again
on the sa page it continued along in a
path
and from the perspective top-down view
it just went another direction so no um
just an instantaneous direction change
from that perspective
you also hear them you know very
excitedly talking on the tapes about um
you know whatever the heck this thing is
and look at the essay there's a whole
formation of them
and so the essay is a situational
awareness page and again it's a large
display that gives that god's eye view
of all the radar context so the video is
actually showing just one
and then they're speaking about many of
them correct on the unless the essay
display correct and what they
essentially saw was if we were
considered above the object north so
kind of offset to the north of the
object
there was a formation of about somewhere
between four and six of these objects in
a rough wedge formation you know so kind
of side by side like this
and again not in a like autopilot type
manner where it was very stiff it was
very kind of
non-mechanical the flight mechanics
again and these objects were in that
formation and they were going along and
then they turned
pretty sharply but they still had a
radius of turn and then went back in the
opposite direction and during that turn
it was they were kind of like all over
the place like it wasn't tight they
weren't even like super i they weren't
flying in a way i would expect them to
be flying in relation to a flight lead
they were flying as if they were flying
close to each other but not in formation
which was kind of strange right
um
and then when they rolled out they kind
of tightened backed up like so when they
basically they started that turn and
then 180 degrees out essentially they
started flowing in the opposite
direction and kind of got back in that
formation and while that was happening
the gimbal object was proceeding we'll
say left to right
and as as those uh the formation kind of
turned up to the north and was just
passing back it the gimbal just kind of
went back in the opposite direction so
to follow it back in that direction
uh and in the in the flare itself you
know you see the object changes
orientation quite a bit so you see it um
more or less level maybe candid about 45
degrees
and then you see it kind of moving
around like this almost as if it was a
gimbal
i've come to learn after some you know
having seen some research online and and
people really looking into this that
it seemed that the object actually
climbed during that maneuver and so the
reason it looked like it turned
immediately is because it turned like
this it turned uh in a vertical fashion
like that which is pretty interesting
that's kind of like another example of a
flight mechanics that we don't normally
operate because we don't change our
directions by maneuvering in the
vertical if we can help it it's
you're just killing the fuel you know
and so the if you're like a surveillance
platform looking to spend as much time
around something you're not gonna
you know climb
500 feet every time you make a turn
unless you're
tom cruise unless you're tom cruise
naturally okay so is that one of the
more impressive flight mechanics you've
seen in in the video in video form so
not the direct
eyesight reports but like in terms of
video evidence that we have i think so
we we were seeing a lot of these but we
weren't just going on recording them all
day we we just kind of put them in that
safety bucket be like all right there's
objects over there we're just not going
to go near it you know and so we weren't
putting our sensors on them that much so
we were gathering the data kind of
secondarily but we weren't primarily
focusing on it to see all the details so
that's so fascinating because you have a
busy day you have a lot to do all right
well there's some weird stuff going on
there we're just not going to go there
and that says something about sort of
the
about human nature about the the way
that bureaucracies function the way the
military functions it fills up your day
with busy important things and you don't
get to um i mean that is something that
i'm
in a sort of absurd way worry about
which is like we fill our days
with so much busyness
then when truly beautiful things happen
whatever they are truly anomalous things
we just won't pay attention
because they don't fit our busy schedule
beautiful i think that's right on the
nose
and it's on my nose because you know i
didn't give this topic the attention it
deserved until i left right until i left
and i went to
be an instructor pilot where
i had more time you know i had more
down time to kind of process and think
and get out of exactly what you just
described and that's kind of what broke
me out of it and got me thinking more
about it
you